business of K-pop is insanely dark and  disturbing you want to keep K-pop stars  as thin as possible so only let them eat  nine paper cups full of grains fruits  and veggies per day let the little cups  you get out of water cooler you also  want to work them like dogs in the gym  that means no rest no breaks and if they  get tired feed them painkillers and make  them keep dancing you also want to make  them bleach their skin remove parts of  their jaw to make them look just right  you also can't let them date because you  want to make them look as accessible to  fans as possible and the best part is  that all of them sign an ironclad  contract when they were just a kid and  they bury themselves into debt for us to  make them into Stars so they have to do  whatever we say to pay us back subscribe  for part two to learn more